let's be honest gamers aren't dropping
gaming as they get older but they are
dropping kids and picking up
responsibilities that cut into their
gaming time and how do you fit get me
into what little time you have sure
you've got your daily spelunky runs your
harsh tone battles over a grilled cheese
at lunch but what's out there first
shooter fan like you have time to
reenlist seven times in titanfall
luckily there is a host of casual
shooter titles that will let you game
one out and call it a night first up
fire up payday 2 for pc ps3 and xbox 360
kids are screaming spouse at Colin you
well then you can pick in game missions
of one to three days depending on your
level you may want to steer clear of
overkill missions but one heist is all
you need for satisfying night completion
of said heist will hopefully net you a
random weapon mod or a mask and a good
cash reward missions can last anywhere
from 10 minutes if you know how to do a
good smash and grab up to say 40 minutes
for a multi-day heist robbery not your
thing at number 2 grab your pc or now
xbox 360 and play war face warning
player population may vary ignoring the
silly g face interface that Crytek came
up with this cooperative shooter picked
you in several other players against
generic bad guy mcvay's very challenging
levels even better Warface actually has
a daily challenge so done and done
Warface will have you back on the couch
before your spouse can say grab the
lotion to rub their feet you perv oh
yeah and it's a free game average round
will run you about 10 to 20 minutes at
number 3 might I recommend Ghost Recon
phantoms on PC also a free title you get
200 in game points for your first win of
the day if you don't want to throw down
for a starter pack pick your favorite
class and stick with it to earn the best
loadout as an added bonus you'll keep
your OB soft combat mechanics sharp
which may come in handy for some
upcoming releases who watch dogs in
division average round time is on the
longer side so expect to put in about 20
to 40 minutes and coming in at number 4
okay okay titanfall you don't have to
reenlist I mean this game literally has
a
art pistol designed for people who don't
have time to keep their twitch skills as
sharp as a twelve-year-old on spring
break the game mechanics are all there
to give players longevity in battle
which means you can spend a maximum
amount of time dropping Titans and a
minimum amount of time looking at the
menu with expedition dlc coming soon
it's a no brainer average time about 10
minutes around well that's it for our
list do you have a busy life and
struggle to find time for gaming what
shooters do you fit into your schedule
you a pvz or a loadout person let us
know in the comments below now go do the
dishes or raise your kids or something
you